blocage perturbations et manifestation
dans toute la France pour cette journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites à Paris la mobilisation est un
succès 800000 personnes selon la CGT
119000 d'après le ministère de
l'intérieur des chiffres records depuis
le début du mouvement ça fait depuis le
début on nous dit qu'on allait pas
respecter rester ensemble dans l'unité
syndicale ou du dit que peut-être il y a
un déclin de la mobilisation je peux
vous dire aujourd'hui il y a un regain
de la mobilisation par rapport à la
dernière fois les gens ne céderont pas
monsieur le Président il ne céderont pas
il s'agit de deux ans de leur liberté
que vous voulez leur confisquer le
gouvernement comptait sur
l'essoufflement du mouvement après le
49-3
y compris après l'intervention du
président de la République
tous les chiffres qui nous remontent
montrent que l'on est dans un très haut
niveau de mobilisation si j'étais
scénique je dirais merci à Macron s'il
pouvait intervenir avant chaque
manifestation ça serait très très bien
voilà parce que c'est ça qui a mis le
les gens
on a eu un président de la République
particulièrement arrogant oh là il y a
c'est jeune elle vous disiez comme vous
êtes bloqué c'est ça euh au de la bribus
vous êtes bloqué vous avez bloqué vous
êtes bloqué vous allez vous allez bloqué
vous êtes en direct sur le site donc
comment ils se font
ça charge de tous les côtés on peut pas
descendre la charge de tous les côtés on
peut pas descendre parce que j'ai
surtout vu c'est des violences des
policiers pour l'instant c'est là que
j'ai vu des charges j'ai vu des jeux de
Grenade et pour l'instant les
manifestants sont joyeux pacifiques
enthousiastes et les seules choses que
je les ai vu incendie et c'est des
poubelles ah mais contentement parfois
exprimé plus violemment alors ayant les
poubelles de ce commissariat ont été
incendie et cet après-midi en marge de
la manifestation il s'est passé
plusieurs choses et il y a également
pardon mais
sérieux tu vas me faire elle vient de se
faire piquer son micro c'est extrêmement
grave et le président de la République
se comporte en République comme un
casseur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui dénonce des attaques inacceptables
et des dégradations vous venez de le
dire contre la sous-préfecture et le
commissariat de Lorient et l'adresse ses
pensées au fonctionnaires blessés le
demande si qu'est-ce qu'il va mettre en
place pour que ça s'arrête on est passé
dans autre chose et que la monarchie
présidentielle ça suffit je suis
quasiment sûr que c'est pour ça sera pas
promulgué par quel biais je ne sais pas
mais je pense que cette loi sera pas
promulguée à l'issue d'une mobilisation
comme celle-ci il ne faut pas être dans
le déni une fois par penser que l'on m'a
effacé les choses il y a un avant il y a
un après et il vient des accords qui va
persister sur la question de l'âge de
départ à la retraite par contre il y a
des sujets et il y a des sujets nombreux
qui permettent de renouer un dialogue je
propose au président retirez votre texte
et donner le dossier à ceux dont c'est
le boulot les conseils d'administration
de les conseils d'administration de la
sécurité sociale où il y a dedans les
patrons et les représentants syndicaux
ben c'est à eux de s'arranger je ne
crois pas du tout
le fait que d'une journée à l'heure être
dans un espace de 12 heures 24 heures on
passe une situation de conflit à une
situation d'entente les choses se font
progressivement cette internaute a eu
l'oeil pendant l'interview d'Emmanuel
Macron hier il a remarqué que le
président qui portait une montre pendant
les 10 premières minutes la retirer
discrètement sous la table chaque
activité normale avant de la poser à
côté au moment où on a un monarque
républicain qui ne tient pas compte du
débat parlementaire et d'un peuple qui
s'exprime et un président qui dit que le
peuple n'est pas légitime on fait appel
à un monarque alors certes qui est qui a
bien moins de pouvoir il a pas le 49-3
lui certains pensent que le chef de
l'État avait oublié qu'il portait une
montre de luxe incompatible avec
l'effort qu'il demande aux Français avec
la réforme des retraites oui peut-être
aux hypothèse la montre tapait un peu
trop fort sur la table il y a les
blocages donc on aura l'occasion sans
doute de pouvoir préciser les forces de
l'ordre qui seront nombreuses pour
accueillir bien évidemment comme il se
doit notre ami britannique
il est le bienvenu parce qu'il
représente le peuple anglais aussi
longtemps que le peuple anglais n'aura
pas fait le nécessaire c'est-à-dire
instaurer une république parce que les
Anglais un jour ou l'autre auront une
République comme les Espagnols et comme
tous les pays libres